all right people we are back with
Justice League versus Godzilla versus
Kong and I know you guys remember the
last video we did right Godzilla helped
Superman finish with all his living
quite literally beat him to death and
then he turned around and killed Adam
Smasher which isn't really surprising
because Adam Smasher sucks but Batman
literally has Superman in a Kryptonian
healing Matrix technically they call it
a solar array but the whole idea is to
bombard this guy with solar energy to
see if they can bring him back now those
of you guys who don't know about the
Kryptonian healing Matrix this was intro
it was it was the dumbest thing ever
right Sidetrack from the story for a
second The Death of Superman in like
1992 or whenever it was that it came out
right Superman gets beat to death by
Doomsday the world's crying fans are
crying it's this great big huge
Monumental thing Hell's Bells they even
had a cover with the Superman logo in
blood it was like the biggest thing ever
right when Superman died so you have
like all these crappy Superman who show
up although cyborg was pretty dope but
eventually Superman comes back right and
what you find out is he was just put in
a cryptonian healing Matrix which was
basically like a Superman Spa right he
got pampered massaged I mean hell he
even came back with a new hairstyle
right the super mullet business in front
party in the back but the whole idea
behind the Kryptonian healing Matrix and
all seriousness is that it is a way for
for Superman to effectively regenerate
because what DC had established over the
years in the comics is that whenever
Superman endures an injury serious
enough that it borderline kills him he
almost kind of goes into quote unquote
hibernation if you want to call it that
it's a very loose term to use here for
what it is that he does but it's more or
less the same thing right and that's
effectively What's Happening Here the
big kicker to this right getting back
into enjoying the story The Big kicker
about this is they don't know if
Superman has a heartbeat right seemingly
Supergirl is the only one that seems to
be able to know if that's the case why I
don't know right maybe maybe it's nobody
has a stethoscope or maybe you need like
a super stethoscope I have no idea but
for whatever reason they don't know
whether he's alive or dead and even
Batman is kind of like panicking in all
of this and the league figures out
pretty fast what Batman needs is
something to focus on because let me
tell you something man Batman dude this
guy's a walking talking McGuffin right
like Batman is prepped for everything
even things that he couldn't possibly be
prepped for right like Batman fights God
he's got a plan for that right because
you know Batman just reach into his
little utility belt and pull out the
anti-god batarang right and he defeats
God right Batman's got he's got a plan
for everything but when you have Batman
in a situation where he's just
emotionally devastated and then you give
him a Target wo be tie that poor soul
because they're going to have to deal
with a pissed off Batman and that is man
is man it is a sight to behold and so
what they do is they kind of compare
notes on everything that's happened so
far and they come to the realization
that Lex Luther and his forces right
like the Legion of Doom which is still
one of the most dope names for a villain
group ever but the Legion of Doom have
been messing with the boom tube and they
somehow got their hands on the
dreamstone the boom tube was a
teleportation device it sent them to an
alternate universe where Godzilla and
all these monsters existed the
dreamstone is an artifact that can bring
what are essentially fictional objects
or dreams into reality in effect it
transported Godzilla and all those guys
here right we didn't go super in-depth
into it before because honestly we
didn't need to because this is really
just a simless explanation and it's all
you need and so their idea is find the
dreamstone we find a way to send
everybody back is it kind of a McGuffin
yeah who cares man because we're here to
see monsters fight the Justice League
who cares about the logic of whether or
not it works and so what you get is
iPhone right cyborg we're calling cyborg
iPhone you get iPhone who ends up
arriving at the last known location of
the beacon which is to say this kind of
device that was emanating a signal a
pulse out there in the world that was
basically drawing all the monsters by
the time iPhone gets out there it's gone
right like it's gone like nobody knows
what in the world this thing is or what
in the world was going on with it more
so than that he tells them that like the
Giant Crab which I have no idea what
that thing's called and it fully
submerged itself right the monster that
was in themira is making its way towards
North America and Godzilla is headed to
Metropolis because as far as they can
guess anyway it's because Superman's
still alive and Godzilla wants to finish
off the Man of Steel and so what you do
is you switch back over to Supergirl now
Supergirl and King Kong this entire time
have just been doing a standoff right
just kind of been staring at each other
because in the last video King Kong
tried to put hands on and Supergirl went
full Charlton hon right like get your
stinking paws off me you damn dirty ape
but ever since then like they've just
been staring at each other and so super
girl comes to the realization that King
Kong isn't really like Godzilla right
just like showing up smack ing Humanity
around a little bit and then leaving
right like he's a little more peaceful
right a little more seemingly capable of
understanding like empathy and that kind
of stuff now it's not to say that
Godzilla does not understand empathy
it's not to say that Godzilla doesn't
understand the struggle of humanity and
how all the damage that he's causing is
just inflicting Untold horror on the
human race it's that Godzilla just
doesn't care right like that's the
difference man so the thing here is that
she basically takes off to go check on
Superman she tells Oliver Queen stay
here keep an eye on this thing right of
course King Kong spins around he's eight
kind of pissed off because Supergirl
took off right like the hot girl
basically bailed and you know now he's
mad at Oliver Queen because Oliver Queen
won't give him Supergirls only fans link
and so what you end up finding out is
that like the two of them are being
watched by the League of Assassins
they're not overly important we're not
going to go into this King Kong just
starts smacking around the League of
Assassins honestly because we want to
see monsters fighting the Justice League
man we do not want to see uh we do not
want to see a guy with a bow who won't
stop stop cracking stupid jokes right
like fight some Assassins right like I
didn't care about Grio after season 1 I
don't care about his character in DC
although the the season with Prometheus
was pretty dope that was a pretty
amazing season but the fact remains here
right Oliver Queen basically baales
jumps on a ship and starts floating away
that'll become important once we get to
the end of this comic but switching back
over to the Justice League Watchtower we
pick up with Lois Lane now in all
seriousness this is something that's
cool and in fact this is something that
I really hope Jes gun eventually focuses
on in Superman Legacy or even the
Superman stories that come after in the
new DC Universe right the relationship
between Superman and Lois Lan because no
they're not married in this reality but
like it's still Superman and Lois right
they're the one two punch of comic book
couples right she is the first lady of
comics and was at one point the
quintessential Damsel in Distress and so
what you get here is when Lois is given
the news about what happened with
Superman she literally shows up to just
see him and it's a very very somber
moment because the Justice League
doesn't know if he's dead and she
doesn't know if he's dead right and so
she says like they said the solar array
isn't healing your damage cells that's
not going to work for me no not after I
found this in your jacket pocket because
he was going to pop the question to her
over dinner and she's like it's
beautiful and my answer is yes so
Superman and Lois are going to get
married in this universe that's awesome
to see that that's still going to happen
right but she's like but you are going
to have to put it on my finger so you'd
better get ready because I really want
to wear it what does all this mean it
most likely means that between Lois Lane
and huy Lewis in the news Superman Will
Survive because that's the power of
love but you end up having like Green
Lantern who shows up and kind of bust in
it's like look I'm sorry to kind of
break in with this whole thing but we
just got an emergency call from Aquaman
that we need to follow up on so do you
want me to take you home and she's like
nope I'm not going anywhere I'm staying
here and if you got a problem with that
you can go one onone with the great one
right and so he's just kind of like do
your thing right stay here and it makes
perfect sense because for Lois like
she's grieving the man she loves in some
capacity because she doesn't know if
he's actually going to die or not she
does even know if he's alive or not so
it's one part grieving one part hoping
but Lois Lane ever the detective it's
one of the things that I love so much
about the character of of Lo right one
of the big influences for the creation
of her character was actually another
fictional character named Torchy Blain
you ever get a chance look up Torchy bla
it's just an amazing concept right like
I do whatever it takes to get the story
reporter like it's it's one of the
coolest things but the whole thing is
Lois starts going through all the video
footage that the Justice League has at
their disposal and she just like makes a
call and she's like it's Lois tell me
every move Lex Luther's made in the past
24 hours and they're like what am I
looking for and she's like like a red
stone right so she's basically on the
hunt for the dream Stone we don't really
know who she's talking to but she's
talking to somebody who's probably going
to show up and play a pretty significant
role here but for the rest of the
Justice League themselves they show up
in Atlantis where you have Aquaman
facing off against a giant sea monster
now I have no idea what this thing's
called and a part of me wants to call it
Steve but the big thing here is Justice
leag kind of asked the question you talk
to fish why don't you talk to that right
but in all ser ious right like this
thing represents a clear and present
danger to Atlantis right like it's just
destroying seemingly everything in sight
a lot of the sea creatures like giant
squid and sharks and things like that
Aquaman's been sending those things
after it and it's been killing them all
honestly I'm not going to lie it a part
of it's kind of funny right like Aquaman
and his aquatic friends doing the best
they can to protect Atlantis from a
giant monster but like he's sending
everything in right great white sharks
giant squid a crab right like he's
sitting in all kinds of stuff and
nothing's happening right like nothing
can be done against this overwhelming
force and so what the Justice League
puts together is that there's actually
multiple beacons that are out there in
the world and they are all drawing these
things to particular locations
specifically one is being drawn here to
Atlantis now putting two and two
together of course these beacons are
basically in places where the creatures
will show up and then hopefully kill
members of the restly but the thing
about this is that they kind of ask the
question how do we defeat this thing
right because one of the first things it
does just blow out a whole bunch of ink
and they're like that can't really be
its only true defense and of course
Green Lantern kind of protects everybody
using his his Green Lantern you know
Powers his hard like constructs and
whatnot but they come to this
realization that there's something else
on its way right because literally
they're told by iPhone right yes like
there is a beacon down there and you
guys need to figure out what's going on
but that's not your biggest issue right
like the biggest issue you have is that
the Metropolis monster is making its way
over there Godzilla is coming right this
thing shows up and just of course as you
guys know right like you guys man y'all
know what's coming y'all know what's
coming you get
that and just bow I blast this thing
with the atomic breath like a beast and
then literally Green Lantern just turns
into like kin wanabi from Godzilla 2014
right just let them fight and so like
they just back off and they let Godzilla
and this thing just go at it with each
other and for the most part Godzilla
looks like he's actually getting wrecked
but then Godzilla turns around puts his
Atomic breath back on this guy and helps
him understand his place in the bigger
picture and so because of the fact that
the fight between Godzilla and this
thing is now really more dangerous than
it was before because before even though
it was kind of a crappy thing to do sea
life could be sacrificed in the name of
preservation right like Godzilla's his
own thinking feeling monster and who
knows what could happen in terms of
collateral damage in fact the fight
between these two could actually lay
waste to the entire city of Atlantis
well really the kingdom of Atlantis so
Aquaman does the only thing he can do he
heads down into the bowels of the
kingdom of Atlantis towards a mighty
chain which he
unlocks and releases the Kraken dude it
is amazing like literally the rcking
gets released and it's only a matter of
time before stuff pops off because what
you do here is you switch back over to
Oliver Queen and Oliver Queen on this
boat stowing away ends up coming across
the head of this just gigantic skull
right this gigantic creature I have no
idea what it is but I'm not going to lie
here guys part of me wants to believe
that it's one of the heads of king
gadora I don't know if it is but if it
is man son son son dude think are going
to go sideways so fast with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end if you need to get caught up on
Justice League Godzilla and Kong make
sure you guys click this link to the
playlist and I will catch you all later
peace